every Irish political party with the
exception of the Greens I think had at
some stage a relationship to the IRA so
Shin feign is no different in that
regard in that there it was and has
always been throughout Irish history a
relationship between the armed rebellion
against British rule and the political
expression of that but the piracy that I
lead is an independent political party
the IRA has gone away the war is over
and Shin Fame is a fully formed
independent democratic political party I
wish I had five points for every person
who said to me he isn't going away you
know Mary Lou MacDonald will be Jerry
Adams puppet will you are you seriously
asking with birds
Nasser's old I mean Jerry has led from
the front for a very long time but I am
the leader of shin vane and I will lead
and I'm not sure how really to interpret
the remarks of those who say that I will
be a papas because anybody who knows me
for any length of time may have their
criticisms of me but being there be no
doubt that I am nobody's poppers
okay convinced them can you point to a
single occasion when you publicly
expressed a difference of opinion with
Jerry Adams or on any issue well I've
had many as the debate many's the
discussion some disagreements but Jerry
I've never felt the need for those to
take public expression and let me tell
you why Jerry and I are on the same team
were members of Sh in vain it's a
political party not a crash or not a
debating society and I've never seen
great merit in political life in people
who go out and backstab or criticize
their colleagues to a third party to the
media or otherwise given what's going on
around
the border over brexit the fact that
there is no power sharing in northern
ireland you've talked about the past
repeating itself do you have a concern
that that could happen no I I don't see
us returning to the circumstances that
fed such a long protracted and deep
conflict no I don't however I am aware
that on the ground in the north over the
last year or so there has been a level
of polarization that I regard as very
dangerous that's why I very much hope
that we get the institution's back up
and running the issues are clear the
issues are resolved about there's
nothing insurmountable in my in my view
but if I'm truthful
they're only sustainable in the long
term when some people step into the
light of the year 2018 when you say some
people you mean Arlene Foster and when
you say the light what exactly do you
mean well I mean quite bluntly that it
is not a sustainable position to argue
that citizens can have marriage equality
in the southern jurisdiction in Ireland
and in England in Wales and Scotland and
somehow the north of Ireland remains you
know cut off from this and citizens
living in the north of Ireland are
denied that basic right that's what I
mean to be blunt is there going to be an
agreement there is already in foster a
woman you can do business with I hope
there will be in agreement and yes I
think we can we can do business with
Arlene Foster no-one has yet been able
to explain how the UK will leave the
customs union and avoid a hard border on
the island of Ireland so what happens if
there is one I mean what can I say
breaks it is an absolute disaster
breaks it and the Good Friday Agreement
aren't mutually incompatible it's as
simple as that
and if I'm honest I sense a real
resentment
around amongst Irish people that Ireland
potentially becomes the collateral
damage in a power play within the Tories
in London so whatever way this plays out
Irish interests and by that I mean the
bread-and-butter interests as much as
the political interests demands thus the
entire island stay inside the customs
union and within the single market and
it is alarming to hear a mantra coming
from London repeated again and again
that you know were gone were off we're
out it seems with absolutely no sense of
the consequences of that
do you believe you will see an artist
unity during your tenure as shin fin
leader I would be hopeful that in the
course of my tenure as as leaders
shouldn't feign that yes that we would
secure a referendum on unity and that we
would win us I I think that's doable
furthermore I want us to achieve and do
those things in an atmosphere of
consensus the maximum consensus possible
there's going to be a referendum on
abortion and Ireland later this year
what's infants position in chin fain
were having that discussion at this
stage we gave a commitment at our last
or adesh our last party conference to
come back again on the issue and we will
do that but you are nor the leader of
this party
are you prepared to tell us what your
personal - absolutely I believe in a
woman's right to choose and that has
been my position for a very very long
time I expressed that very openly my
priority colleagues are well aware of
that and that's that's the position that
I take on these matters
the Irish Prime Minister on Tisch Utley
over at Carr has described Mary Lou
McDonald as cranky what one word would
you use to describe the Irish Prime
Minister
indeed they've caught me there one word
to describe smarmy it was kind of smarmy
you'd have seen him in number 10 talking
about Love Actually and sort of darling
various pairs of socks
so smarmy is my one word